okay let's go back to the pigeonhole
thing here how do you clean your room
when your spouse doesn't share that goal
huh
well that's another one of those
questions it's really hard to answer
because I don't have the details you
know how do you clean your room what
goals does your spouse have that's the
first thing I mean do is there some
commonality I mean it might be maybe
you're a spouse is much more disorderly
than you or less conscientious or
irritated at you for all sorts of
reasons you know the first thing you
could do is try to lead by example and
see how that works but you may have to
argue and fight it out you know break it
down into subtasks and and see if you
can distribute the the tasks and
negotiate you have to negotiate and
without further information I can't say
much more than that you know you can say
why you're doing it what you think the
goal were and goal was and that you'd
like some help and maybe there's
something you could offer in return
if you can't negotiate it all with your
spouse then you have a much broader
problem then how do you clean your room
when your spouse doesn't share that goal
because the real problem would be how do
you learn to negotiate with your spouse
I could talk about that a little bit I
mean the first thing that you have to do
if you want to negotiate with someone is
be able to say no the second thing is to
have something to offer the third thing
is to find out what they want and to
know what you want you know because
often people especially with people that
love them they say well if you really
knew if you really loved me then you'd
know what I want it's like no that's
just wrong
the person that you are in love with or
that living with isn't any smarter than
you and so you pretty much always have
to tell people straight out what you
want and then you have to let them be
really stupid about giving it to you for
quite a while you know so sometimes I've
recommended to my clients that they take
their wife or husband out on a date and
of course they're all skeptical about
that and cynical about it and then they
go on a date and they have a terrible
time and they come back and say I told
you that was a stupid idea and I tell
them a lot that's it then a you're not
gonna do anything romantic
with your spouse for the next 40 years
that's your plan that's the plan is it
it's like you might have to go out to a
movie after you haven't been good to
each other for like five years you might
have to go out to a movie ten times
movie and dinners say before it starts
to become fun again it's like it's hard
to do that sort of thing right you know
people think those things are easy and
they're not so anyways you have to you
have to learn to negotiate with your
spouse and that's a very difficult thing
to do so figuring out what you want is a
good way to start so